hey what's up this is dr. John Delaney
with Ramsey Network we are continuing
part three of our anxiety series in
video one I told you that anxiety is
just a fire alarm most of the time it is
not the problem our lives are our lack
of relationships are in the second video
we talked about five things you can do
right now
when you feel your anxiety alarms
spinning up and starting to ring and
ring in ring today's video I'm going to
talk about what are things we can do to
change our lives what are ways we can
fireproof our homes there are alarms and
never go off or when they do go off we
know there's major problems in the
neighborhood so a quick refresher if you
feel your anxiety alarms starting to
spin up number one write your thoughts
and feelings down and do a quick is it
real or is it not number two write down
what you can control and what you can't
control
and let the things you can't control go
number three take care of your body as
cheesy as it sounds
getting your breath under control helps
exercise sleep eat right we're going to
talk about some of those things today as
more of a long-term strategy but it also
works in the short term too number four
connect with a friend connect with a
group right away and again we're going
to talk about that today as well it's
part of a long term strategy and number
five be a person of gratitude
immediately sit down and write down five
things you are grateful for
so long-term strategy number one examine
the ecosystem of your life what do I
mean by ecosystem my son is 10 and the
local schools are already asking him
where he's going to go to college what
do you want to be when he grows up what
are the things he's doing right now to
achieve his goals the dude is 10 right
we have set up an environment where we
all tell ourselves that we need to be
all things to all people all the time we
need to have a plan for 5 years in 10
years and 20 years down the road and if
we get off that plan there's something
wrong with us not the plan we're told
that we're responsible for everybody
else's feelings and that our goal in
relationships is to be right and to get
things from each other not to just be
with one another we don't know how to be
married anymore
we don't know how to have kids anymore
we don't know how to deal with
technology in our lives and our houses
are on fire and so when I say examine
your ecosystem sit down with yourself
sit down with your partner sit down with
your kids if they're old enough and
paint a picture of what you want this to
look like what do you want your life to
look like not where do you want to be in
five years
and what title do you want to have and
what amount of money do you want to make
because here's what sucks about living
that life no matter what job you get you
go with you no matter how much money you
have in your bank account you're the one
that has to go deposit that money the
worst part about getting a new
girlfriend a new boyfriend a new husband
is that you go with you if you don't do
the hard work of identifying the
ecosystem that you want to create you're
never gonna be whole it's time to take
inventory of your life it's time to look
around at your ecosystem what are things
you need to say no to what are
boundaries you need to put up what are
relationships that you need to fix
because you're doing things that aren't
helpful
what are new books you need to read what
are new people you need to connect with
examine the ecosystem of your life
number two I talked about this in the
last video and I'm gonna expand on it
here we've got to take care of our
hearts our minds our souls and our
bodies chronic stress is killing us it
is killing us this isn't a game it's not
a game mindfulness prayer belief in God
those aren't funny things that we used
to do long ago and now suddenly we've
got iPhones in sophistication and we
don't need to honor our hearts and our
minds anymore wrong you have to submit
to something bigger than you I'm a
Christian guy so I buy into a Christian
God you've got to meditate you've got to
pray those are non negotiables for a
healthy stress-free alarm free life
you've got to exercise pull up the
Internet's there's a thousand different
workouts most professionals that I talk
to now when I ask them what's the best
workout you can do they say anyone that
you will stick with
yoga heavy lifting running I don't care
do what works for you but you got to do
something you got to take care of your
mind
I know tiger King was fun but a good
book would have been better I know just
scrolling through Netflix and spending
mindless hours on different apps and
scrolling machine thingies feels good
it's a distraction but it doesn't feed
our minds to give your mind your body
your spirit your soul take care of
yourself number three invest in new and
existing relationships as I talked about
in the last video we cannot do life
alone we can't and that means we have to
learn how to do things like say I'm
sorry I screwed it up I shouldn't have
been texting her I shouldn't have called
him I need to be a better dad and I'm
sorry learning how to say I need help
my alarms are spinning I can't pick up
this couch by myself my wife is sad and
it's my fault and I don't know what to
do
learning to look somebody in the eye and
say I love you and I haven't done it
right all the time but I love you I
don't want to get this right
finding people to invest in to loved
over the long term one of my mentors dr.
Richard Beck asked a question that still
haunts me
he said what if we lived our lives as
that we would never move what
conversations would we have with our
neighbors our church members our friends
what ways would we treat people when we
messed up instead of running away
finding a new church home moving to a
new house taking a new job what if we
worked hard on the relationship that we
have what if we took care of our loved
ones and we said I'm sorry I'm gonna do
better next time
number four when you need it get
professional help I've seen a counselor
I've seen a medical doctor there was a
season I was on medication I've worked
with all different kinds of people from
single moms with three kids to
multimillionaires who are all struggling
with the same anxiety alarms nobody's
immune and there's moments in time when
we have to submit and Saturday December
national help get the help you need you
are worth it if you've got somebody in
your life that needs help encourage them
to get the professional help that they
need so a quick recap examine your
ecosystem and take an inventory of your
life your relationships and the things
you think you want to do number two take
care of your mind your body your spirit
your soul number three take care of and
invest in new relationships we cannot do
this alone
number four when necessary get
professional help don't be ashamed to go
see a counselor don't be ashamed to go
visit with your pastor don't be ashamed
sit with your wife or your husband or
your girlfriend or your boyfriend and
say together let's go talk to somebody
do these four things and you will begin
to fireproof your life and one day in
the near future you'll wake up and
you'll realize the alarms have stopped
that you've regained control of your
thoughts and your actions and your life
is on a different trajectory and it's a
trajectory of peace and of joy and a
feeling of lightness that you can't
understand until you experience it for
yourself you can do it and I'm here to
walk alongside you this is John dallona
with Ramsey Network subscribe to all the
things change your thoughts change your
actions and you will change your life
you can do this talk to you soon